yannick jadot la tête de liste europe
écologie les verts pour les européennes
est l'invité d'auditions publiques
bonsoir et merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous d'avoir répondu présent à ce rendez
vous donc des chaînes parlementaires de
la sp et du figaro et si vous suivez
d'ailleurs l'émission sur le figaro live
via le chat vous pouvez réagir et même
un inter réagir en posant vos produits
vos propres questions et je me ferais
votre relais sur ce plateau alors
l'écologie bien sûr yannick jadot est au
coeur de tous les débats et de toutes
les colères aujourd'hui face à un
gouvernement qui donc a décidé de tenir
bon face au gilet jaune qui n'ont pas
désarmé partout en france vous l'avez vu
encore aujourd'hui vous répondrai donc
au cours de cette émission à charles
sapin stéphanie le rouge déjà présents
le figaro et la sp également à oriane
mancini et brigitte boucher et puis à
deux parlementaires qui nous rejoindrons
tout à l'heure le député en marche
damien pichot et le sénateur et l'ère
jean françois husson qui d'ailleurs elle
lui a calculé pour un rapport sénatorial
l'impact de la hausse des taxes nous en
dira plus tout à l'heure mais d'abord
yannick jadot une question sur carlos
ghosn qui donc aujourd'hui arrêtée au
japon le grand patron de renault nissan
des soupçons de fraude fiscale quelle
est votre réaction à ce que l'on
présente déjà comme sa chute lui que
vous n'avez pas ménagé encore dans un
passé récent
c'est un fraudeur en série un fraudeur
fiscal
on le voit au japon est un fraudeur en
tant que patron de renault il faut
savoir qu'il ya plus de deux millions de
véhicules renault qui sont en
circulation dans notre pays qui explose
totalement les normes de pollution
diesel et co2 qui les explose
frauduleusement
mais à la différence de l'allemagne où
le gouvernement à imposer aux
constructeurs automobiles de rappeler
les voitures pour recalibrer les moteurs
pour finir avec la fraude
le gouvernement français n'a jamais rien
exiger de sa console rôdeur enserrer
vous fait le lien en sorte ces affaires
pistes fiscales qui lui sont reprochés à
l'onu et puis la conduite de son
entreprise bien sûr parce que pour les
français pour les français ya fois un
sentiment profond d'injuste
si c'est pas la première fois que carlos
ghosn apparaît dans les médias pour
avoir défendu des salaires totalement
mirobolants yannick jadot au delà du
dérapage fiscal de l'homme que l'
enquête judiciaire nous apprendra
peut-être sûrement plus en détail le
bilan de cet homme à la tête d'un géant
il a quand même porté nissan renault à
un sommet inédit il a investi avant
beaucoup de ses concurrents sur le
véhicule électrique notamment pour vous
c'est quoi c'est une mauvaise décision
s'est il faut finalement faut mettre
tous vos griefs dans le même sac et je
t'ai donne moi le bilan je fais
aujourd'hui il y compris en tant que
député européen
j'ai vu comment le groupe renault à
l'identique le groupe et ça comme
volkswagen et les autres interférer
brutalement avec tous les processus de
décision européen pour réduire leurs
contraintes en matière d'émissions de
co2 en matière d'émissions de dioxyde
d'azoté ce qui est le problème du diesel
et à chaque fois que vous réduisez vos
contraintes en matière de co2 comme en
matière de diesel vous réduisez les
contraintes en matière de consommation
carburant par exemple très électrique
c'est une c'est quelque chose très bien
très bien dans la voiture électrique
très bien d'investir sur des modes
alternatifs mais je regrette que nos
deux groupes français
ce qui doit quitter la tête du groupe
claire à partir du moment où s'il était
avéré que il est mêlé à une fraude
fiscale ça serait totalement aberrant
qu'il reste à la tête du groupe
on a déjà eu un conseil d'administration
à free qui n'a pas qui n'a jamais écouté
l'état sur le plafonnement de ces
salaires qui sont totalement mirobolants
totalement en dehors de toute réalité de
rémunération et là s'il était avéré que
il est coupable de fraude fiscale au
japon
évidemment il ne peut pas rester à la
tête du groupe a à présent vous êtes
réjouit ce soir vous parlez d'un
fraudeur a serré
moi je vous savez vous êtes content de
voir arrêter non non non pas du tout
alors vous savez moi je suis extrêmement
inquiets à partir du moment où des
groupes automobiles sont pris en
flagrant délit de fraude aux
consommateurs un véhicule en moyenne en
europe ça vous l'avez vous avez démarré
en vendant gagné le bras armé d'un homme
à abattre
attendez attendez à partir du moment où
pour en moyenne chaque véhicule européen
consomme 400 euros de plus de carburant
que ce qui est vendu aux consommateurs
donc j'appelle ça une fraude
à partir du moment où vous avez là
l'absolue nécessité que les français
retrouve de la confiance à la fois dans
leurs dirigeants politiques mais aussi
dans l'ain dirigeants des groupes privés
des groupes qui font l'économie à partir
du moment où une personne est en rupture
par rapport à cette confiance le mieux
c'est qu'il parte mais je viens
d'arrêter à voir quand il était à un
grand visionnaire je ne me réjouis pas
une seconde à que un groupe français se
retrouve coincé à la fois sur la fraude
au consommateur sur la fraude aux
citoyens pour la pollution comme sur la
fraude de son dirigeant en matière
fiscale
c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle parce
que ça casse en permanence la confiance
qu'ont les français et dans le monde
politique et dans le monde économique et
que franchement en ce moment a ajouté de
la défiance à la défiance est une très
mauvaise nouvelle et pour notre économie
et pour notre démocratie voilà pour
carlos ghosn donc parlons maintenant des
gilets jaunes
yannick jadot est ce que le gouvernement
peut dire j'entends la colère et la
colère qui perd tu as perdu au jeu je
disais encore aujourd'hui et ne pas
bouger
non c'est totalement aberrant vous savez
moi je soutiens la fiscalité écologique
il faut sortir du carbone il faut sortir
du diesel on voit les feux de forêt
enfin les cheveux bien au delà des
forêts encore un californie on l'a vu si
on les a vus cet été en europe
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique
est une nécessité absolue
le diesel en france ces dix mille morts
prématurées par ornements et là donc ils
ont la grâce qualité quand j -ph
delahaye qui serait donc il faut de la
fiscalité écologique en revanche ce
qu'ont toujours dit les écologistes
c'est que chaque euro prélevé doit être
rendu aux français pour les accompagner
dans cette transition
aujourd'hui c'est très très loin d'être
le cas donc ça participe d'un ras-le-bol
fiscale et ça participe au fond de faire
porter le coût de la transition sur des
personnes qui n'ont pas les moyens ce
que vous n'avez jamais et je rejoindrai
yannick jadot c'est finalement un
mauvais aiguillage des bénéfices de cet
acte donc c'est à dire que vous
préfériez que le bénéfice de cet axe ait
davantage par une transition énergétique
je ne crois pas que les jaunes défilent
pour cette raison ils portent plutôt un
mécontentement un ras-le-bol fiscale ils
veulent des insignes pour le pouvoir
d'achat
finalement que ces taxes finances la
transition écologique ou non j'ai pas
sûr que ce soit le principal problème
ici je crois qu'aujourd'hui le
consentement à l'impôt dans notre pays
c'est profondément affaissé ces
dernières années il s'est profondément
aspect c'est parce que il ya un
sentiment d'injustice sociale liée à
l'injustice fiscale
à partir du moment où ce quinquennat a
commencé avec la suppression de l'impôt
sur la fortune il y a eu l'idée
on a eu la les apl on a eu la cg mais
bon on line et les taxes on a une âme et
je soutiens moi je suis pour l'impôt
vous savez les gens qui m'avaient vous
êtes pour la trajectoire de la hausse
prévue pour le 2 à 6 ans aux risques
pour la sueur simplement jeudi apa à
partir du moment où on est dans cette
nécessaire transition
il faut tout faire pour accompagner les
françaises et les français dans ce
changement ce pour quoi c'est pourquoi
beaucoup manifestent c'est la question
du pouvoir d'achat
si on investit comme on devrait faire
comme nous le demandons sur la
rénovation thermique de nos logements ce
sont des emplois dans toutes nos zones
rurales dans tous nos quartiers dans
tous nos centres villes quand nous nous
battons sur les énergies renouvelables
ce sont des emplois dans toutes les
régions y compris celles qui sont
désertés quand nous nous battons sur
d'autres formes de mobilité s'est aussi
accompagné les françaises et les
français dans
liberté ça demande une grenelle
finalement pour financer la transition
énergétique le ps et le pcf dit il faut
geler la progression actuelle des taxes
pour éventuellement faire ce grenelle
est ce que c'est une proposition vous
partager non non je pense que si vous
voulez je suis toujours attristé quand
ceux qui se revendiquent aujourd'hui de
l'écologie et vous m'avez régulièrement
interrogé sur a mais aujourd'hui tout le
monde fait de l'écologie
donc finalement y'a pas besoin des
écologistes non moi je suis pas pour un
jour je défend l'écologie
le lendemain je souffle sur les braises
des colères ou ge attise les peurs ou ja
tease les le désarroi donc je suis pas
pour cette logique là en revanche la
proposition de laurent berger est une
excellente proposition
il faut remettre aujourd'hui de
l'intelligence collective dans ce débat
créer moi j'étais un initiateur et un
négociateur du grenelle de
l'environnement on avait les
collectivités locales
l'enjeu majeur d'avoir les élus locaux
autour de la table les associations
représentant les familles les
associations représentant les
consommateurs les associations de
protection de l'environnement
les syndicats représentant les salariés
l'état évidemment et il faut qu'ils
aient des représentants du régime et
chaud non parce que ce sera un
renoncement mais parce que le
gouvernement est dirigé par bercy on est
dans un dans une absurdité politique
aujourd'hui bercy dit probant va réduire
de 5 euros les appelle ça va pas se voir
c'est un bordel absolue alors
aujourd'hui dans le logement vous avez
bercy qui dit mais si on déclare à la
télé quand le quand on envoie le premier
ministre ministre des finances que on va
vous inquiétez pas sûr de pouvoir
d'achat
il va y avoir l'inversion de la courbe
de la tendance que le pouvoir d'achat
que vous perdez aujourd'hui vous être
récupéré dans tout ça c'est de la
bouillie
personne ne comprend rien en revanche
avoir ce grenelle de la transition où
tous les acteurs sont associés pour
décider et de la collecte de l'argent
sur l'écologie mais comment on
accompagne les familles comment on
investit et je vais aller plus loin que
genre donnez moi je rebondis sur ce que
vous avez 10 secondes
les plus loin il faut ce grenelle de la
transition et pour ma part je suis
favorable à ce qu'on crée aujourd'hui la
sécu de l'environnement après la seconde
guerre mondiale il y avait deux enjeux
majeurs la santé le social on a mobilisé
l'ensemble de la société
pour y faire face et on a mis tous les
acteurs importants autour de la table
comme gouvernance moi je veux que face
aux grands défis de l'environnement en
face à la sécu ou l'environnement qui
serait bien ce serait de réorganisation
structurelle de sat accompagnement de la
tentation qu l'habitude de
l'environnement bah oui c'est toute la
fiscalité écolo c'est l'idée qui est là
qui irait là et on mettrait tous les
acteurs concernés pour les aider à
organiser la transition qu'on fasse les
meilleurs investissements qu'on fasse
les meilleures règles qu'on fasse la
meilleure des fiscalités c'est un enjeu
qui est telle qu'on ne peut pas laisser
quiconque sur le bord de la route ce qui
est très intéressant c'est à vous
écouter on dirait qu'il n'y a qu'une et
une seule vision de l'écologie vous
discutez d'ailleurs si je comprends bien
ce que vous venez dire vous discutez
finalement la possibilité d'autres
parties de porter des voix écologistes
pourtant il ya d'autres visions de
l'écologie on envoie une qui prend
d'avant de plus en plus d'ampleur une
écologie finalement plus conservatrice
qui qui est porté notamment avec une
vision des limites avec par exemple un
retour des frontières pour protéger des
espaces délimités
que pensez vous de cette écologique est
porté par exemple par un intellectuel
comme hervé juvin qui sera probablement
sur la liste du rassemblement national
pour les européennes
pour vous c'est ça apporte quelque chose
à la cause écologiste ou pas du tout
mais vous savez - ya vingt ans quand
j'étais à greenpeace
on était tout seul sur l'écologie n'est
pas grand monde aujourd'hui tout le
monde en parle tant mieux c'est notre
victoire aussi que au fond lié ces
majorités culturel nom parle culture et
noir pour vous mais que tout le monde en
parle c'est une victoire culturelle
aujourd'hui sur la question des
pesticides sur la question des énergies
renouvelables sur la question du
logement sur la question des mobilités
tout le monde est d'accord pour avancer
simplement il ya ceux qui en parlent il
ya ce qu'ils font nous on fait au
parlement européen il y en a beaucoup
qui en parlent et qui finalement renonce
mais sur
vision conservatrice que vous mentionnez
de l'écologie derrière des frontières
franchement la biodiversité le climat la
protection des océans l'échelon
pertinent c'est l'échelon européen à la
fois pour porter aujourd'hui
malheureusement contre trump contre
poutine contre pour partie les chinois
contre bolton arrow maintenant au brésil
pour porter cette idée qu'on a une
communauté de destin mondial qu'il faut
qu'on organise ensemble la protection du
climat de la biodiversité et la
solidarité c'est l'échelon européen et
pour être capable justement au sein de
l'union européenne
d'investir moi je porte l'europe des
terroirs savez cette capacité corps et
l'europe à aider les territoires les
terroirs à organiser la transition
agricole la transition énergétique la
transition sur les mobilités la culture
tout ça on a besoin de l'europe
franchement l'écologie derrière nos
frontières aujourd'hui c'est totalement
absurde
alors c'est pas tout à l'heure que bercy
gouvernent est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que le gouvernement essaie
de se refaire une virginité écologique
en affichant sa fermeté sur ce sujet
alors que nicolas hulot est parti alors
qu'il est attaqué par exemple sur sa
décision sur l'huile de palme alors que
la montagne d'or etc
quand nicolas hulot a négocié son
ministère il avait très clairement dit
ce ministre de la transition écologique
et solidaire
l'aspect solidarité a malheureusement
totalement disparu aujourd'hui
l'écologie telle que portée par ce
gouvernement est finalement en train de
dégoûter une partie de nos concitoyens
du combat écolo voire de la protection
de leur propre santé
parce qu'à force de leur dire que
l'écologie ça n'est qu'une contrainte
c'est finalement taxer ceux qui sont
dans une situation la plus difficile
mais que finalement ça sert à jouer
du des effets de de bolt au entre la
taxe d'habitation la csg là les apl la
liesse f
la flat tax sur l'état tout le monde
personne ne comprend plus rien et il ya
ce sentiment d'être grugés et j je suis
surpris d'ailleurs que ce gouvernement
prétendent le faire au nom de l'écologie
quand il s'agit d'abord d'une fiscalité
de rendement c'est-à-dire qu'il s'agit
d'abord d'abonder le budget général et
non pas d'organiser la transition
écologique parce que quand vous avez
quand vous êtes contraint sur vos
transports
si vous payez plus vos carburant est ce
que ça vous fait changer de mode de
transport s'il n'y a pas de ligne de 2,2
de train pour vous mais qu'on porte
atteinte à la cause écologiste a va
quand même un moment donné il a dit avec
les 80 km/h c'est très impopulaire
attention c'est l'écologie non les 80 km
c'est un enjeu de sécurité routière mais
d'un seul coup au fond quand c'est mal
perçu
il veut mettre ça sur le land de
l'écologie sur le mode à l'écologie
c'est mal mais il faut faire donc je le
fais non il dit pas assez
monsieur macron à quel point l'écologie
peut être porteuse d'une reconstruction
de ces idées pourquoi est-ce pardonnez
moi pourquoi les personnes aujourd'hui
le manifeste est pourquoi beaucoup sont
en situation difficile parce que depuis
des décennies on apportait un
aménagement du territoire qui nous
oblige à faire des kilomètres et des
kilomètres qui a favorisé la grande
distribution les hypermarchés en
banlieue ou en zone rurale
isolé plutôt que les commerces de centre
ville qui a réduit les petites lignes de
chemin de fer qui a en permanence créer
les conditions pour qu'on soit obligé de
faire des kilomètres et des kilomètres
et des kilomètres pour accéder à un
service de classe alors dans les
manifestations vous n'êtes pas allé non
parce que ces manifestations s'oppose à
la fiscalité colonnes moi je veux une
transition énervé quand vous avez les
cheveux transition sur les avais dit
votre frustration parce que edouard
philippe est venu à la télévision il ya
soit sans aucune proposition nouvelle en
revanche c'est un coin c'est incroyable
vous avez dit que c'était un vrai rang
pour vous en revanche c'est ce que c'est
aberrant de pointe et le danger de
l'anarchie sas à ce que l'on constate
une dérégulation de la contestation est
ce que elle est lourde de menaces pour
le pays aujourd'hui on est aujourd'hui
face à des mouvements intel ras-le-bol
dans notre société que y compris nous
avons une responsabilité politique
majeur je n'ai dit tout à l'heure tous
ceux qui participent d'attiser les
colères de souffler sur les braises
on fond ne répond pas à la responsable
non je vais d'ailleurs quand on est un
responsable politique quand on a un élu
notre honneur notre responsabilité c'est
de répondre aux colères c'est pas de les
attiser
il y a eu dans ses manifestations des
comportements absolument inadmissible
alors soyez pas homophobe et xénophobes
des comportements de contre un dn même
quand ils font des cdd des blocages
filtrants vous soutenez vous affichez
que vous soutenez vous passez vous
n'êtes pas forcément favorable à ces
blocages
vous êtes bloqués donc c'est pas comme
ça qu'est ce que des responsables de
partis ont soufflé sur les braises bien
sûr qu'ils avaient sur dérivés écoutez
vous avez kiki qui a soutenu qu'ils
appelaient la mobilisation vous avez le
front national vous avez les
républicains vous avez une position mi
figue mi raisin comme d'habitude du
parti socialiste et puis vous avez très
clairement la france a soumises et
finalement 7
cette colère hier hier marine le pen
était invité du grand jury elle appelé
finalement les gilet jaune le peuple
centrale elle se disait légitime de
porter de d'être leur porte voix dans le
bureau d'edouard philippe pour vous
c'est une crainte à sept mois des
européennes que finalement à la ramasse
la mise à chaque fois qu'on laisse
s'installer l'idée que les dirigeants
n'entendent pas le ras-le-bol
n'entendent pas la colère n'entendent
pas le désarroi on favorise le populisme
pourquoi je me bats autant contre le
statu quo libéral technocratique tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui installé en europe
et que porte emmanuel macron c'est parce
que tant que vous laissez ces politiques
se développer comme elle se développe
vous n'êtes pas le rempart des
populistes vous n'êtes pas le rempart
des externes vous devenez leur marche
pied merci pour cette première partie
merci à tous deux il est encore des tas
de questions mais les questions seront
posées dans la suite de l'émission et
notamment avec les deux parlementaires
qui font maintenant leur entrée sur le
plateau
et vous messieurs j'ai juste le temps de
donner tient une réaction paritaire sur
le plateau vous en faites partie moi
aussi c'est comme ça on s'excuse mais on
essaiera d'améliorer les choses dans la
dernière partie des missions ça y est
très dur à tous les cas j'en profite
pour donner la réaction d'un internaute
qui réagit sur le figaro live qui
comprend pas votre position et yannick
jadot kiliba attendez vous êtes pour la
hausse des taxes sur les carburants mais
vous êtes contre le matraquage fiscal
vous êtes contradictoires c'est pas
simple à comprendre la position à
l'éclair chaque euro collecté doit être
rendu aux français pour les accompagner
voilà c'est fait ça très bien
alors avec nous donc le député la
république en marche et du de la sarthe
damien pichereau bonsoir et avoue côté
le sénateur et l'air de meurthe et
moselle jean-françois husson bonsoir et
si je vous dis messieurs est ce que vous
considérez tous ici être écologiste levé
la main droite et dire je le suis je le
suis sans aucun souci avec bonheur et
plaisir
je suis évidemment bain en quelle est
votre différence parce que ça fait je me
suis engagé en politique ça fait 20 ans
que je porte dans mon territoire
les enjeux de l'environnement de
l'écologie
donc c'est vraiment sans complexe et
parce que j'ai également avec d'autres
évidemment parce que c'est pas ça n'est
pas qu'une aventure personnelle j'ai
animé j'ai coordonné j'ai souhaité faire
bouger les lignes en tous les cas
rassembler je peux juste vous dire que
pendant deux mandats au grand nancy nous
avons quasiment adopté à l'unanimité
toutes les décisions touchant à
l'environnement
un exemple je parlais le soutien
d'europe écologie
alors rien vous donner un seul exemple
la seule fois où on a changé une
chaufferie charbon par un une comment
dirais-je une connexion sur un réseau de
chaleur urbain avec une chaufferie bois
le seul élu sur 80 qui c'est qui a voté
contre
c'était un élu qui se disait vert alors
quel est votre question tête de liste
europe écologie la première question
j'ai entendu le fanatisme
pour l'appétit de fiscalité verte la
fiscalité verte vient d'augmenter
fortement dans tous les cas c'est voulu
comme ça par le gouvernement d'edouard
philippe et avec le président de la
république emmanuel macron l'an la taxe
carbone et la convergence essence diesel
excusez moi sur les cinq ans ces 46
milliards d'euros supplémentaires
vous venez de dire qu'ils voient donc
prélevé sur les français est grosso modo
aujourd'hui 20% seulement qui sont
dirigés vers l'accompagnement des
mesures et dans les français donc
puisque vous êtes pour cette fiscalité
verte qui contraint qui quelque part
aujourd'hui à tendance plutôt qu
accompagner à punir
expliquez-moi comment vous pouvez encore
aujourd'hui considérer que c'est la
seule le seul moyen la seule arme pour
aider les français à bouger moi j'ai
d'autres idées mais expliquez moi quel
est votre conviction parce que on sent
que le bâton fiscale finalement il
provoque un certain plaisir chez les
verts alors je suis pas un fanatique la
france au niveau européen et dans le
wagon que de la fiscalité écologique il
ya beaucoup d'autres pays qui font
beaucoup plus l'idée de la fiscalité
c'est quoi c'est de faire évoluer les
comportements et les stratégies
d'investissement
l'enjeu essentiel c'est évidemment la
visibilité ce qui manque d'ailleurs dans
le moment il faudrait peut-être avoir
une réflexion d'ailleurs sur la tei pp
flottante
ce qui manque dans le moment c'est comme
en famille jusqu'à maintenant mais ce
qui manque dans le moment en fait c'est
une sorte de lisibilité
on va devoir attendre et de lisibilité
de la fiscalité pour les français et
qu'ils comprennent à quel point il avait
engagé
vous parlez de 54 milliards le remake 29
46 46 vous avez parlé 46 milliards
imaginez que ses 46 milliards soit
intégralement investis dans la
rénovation thermique du logement mais ce
n'est pas le cas donc parler des nommés
fois par jour et je suis pas au
gouvernement mais moi non plus mais
voudra les d'avril il faut parler de
l'asie aujourd'hui on a une trajectoire
que le gouvernement américain
moi je suis pas sûr que non mais vous
êtes en train de dire que je vais être
comptable de la politique du
gouvernement vous démange et abondamment
kitty gré ou demander beaucoup plus de
fiscalité verte je pense que c'est bien
de la bonne solution et notamment quand
on accélère la pente de la taxe carbone
j'ai dit je vais juste vous dire vous
pourrez vérifier dangereux officiel le
24 novembre dernier lorsque nous a
demandé d'adopter le la trajectoire pour
cinq ans j'ai fait une remarque de forme
qui est premièrement on ne peut pas nous
demander de voter à la veuve sans
connaître le contexte et pour cinq ans
résultat j'ai dit il est hors de
question prenez l'exemple du grenelle de
l'environnement votée à la quasi
unanimité par les deux assemblées qui a
été arrêtée brutalement par une ministre
avec les bonnets rouges
il n'est pas question de refaire les
bonnets rouges autour de la taxe carbone
c'est pourtant ce qui se passe en ce
moment alors on va donner comme mission
le sénateur ni des alternatives alors
plutôt que non mais c'est comme un
accouchement mais c'est très simple
c'est de travailler plus sur la
réglementation compte j'ai conduit la
commission d' enquête sur la pollution
de l'air l'ensemble de nos partenaires
que vous avez fêté la première parisien
louis bien sûr l'ensemble de nos
partenaires nous ont dit à choisir entre
une fiscalité de la réglementation de la
réglementation puisque la fiscalité
monsieur le député travaille et je pense
que je peux pas répondre à ma silva m
monsieur pichereau envie de l'entendre
mais oui moi j'ai envie de dire encore
des mots toujours des mots les mêmes
mots ça fait 30 ans que j'entends un
discours le même discours où il faut
faire plus il faut sortir du co2 j'ai 30
ans est en général s'est resserré sa
tasse à l'écologie depuis quand les
sorties on a grandi avec
maintenant ce que je vois bien c'est que
vous proposez rien sans voir ce que
j'entends et quand vous dites tout ça
c'est de la bouillie les gens n'y
comprennent rien c'est à peu près ce que
vous proposez ce soir les gens n'y
comprennent rien d'accord tout
simplement comment vous financez vous
dites chaque euro collecté doit être
versée aux français mais c'est déjà ce
qu'on fait en quelque sorte dont on
rappelle que cette année par exemple ati
ses preuves a rapporté 37 milliards
d'euros
on a déjà 35 qu'il convient lancé ce
qu'elle sait combien la fiscalité
écologique au total on est à + 5
millions d'euros on est d'accord non 50
milliards milliards plus tôt
dakar 10 millions donc 2 à 2 vous voyez
qu'il ya un décalage entre l'ensemble de
la fiscalité écolo et le budget du
ministère ça tombe bien puisqu'il n'ya
pas que le ministère qui finance la
fiscalité écologique dans l'accord la
barre quand quand on demande un plan
massif d'investissement dans la
rénovation même nicolas hulot qui a
quitté le gouvernement l'a dit quand il
est parti il a dit on a sur un objectif
de 500 milles rénovation thermique par
an avec un objectif prioritaire qui sont
les passoires énergétiques et d'un voilà
quand vous dites qu'on a des
propositions mais c'est ça qu'il faut
faire quand vous touchez comment sans
augmenter la fiscalité mais justement
d'allouer cette fiscalité écolo à
l'investissement dans la rénovation
quand vous venez de réduire le le crédit
d'impôt sur la transition énergétique
vous venez de le diviser par deux vous
n'êtes mettre en difficulté un bon
nombre d'artisans qui s'était engagé qui
investissent et sur le changement de
fenêtre un certain nombre de rénovation
des logements qui étaient très efficaces
au regard de ce que dit thierry repentin
on sait aussi donc c'est la correction
d'additionnalité cette folie depuis il a
eu aussi un effet d'arrêter les arts
verts qui a créé un effet d'aubaine vous
réalisation à la tous vous réduisez
l'investissement dans la transition
énergétique au moment nous vous avez une
fiscalité qui augmente moi ce que je
propose c'est le triplement du chèque
énergie en base non bah oui finance vous
gagnez 4 milliards de 2018 à 2019 vous
avez 4 milliards en plus le triplement
du chèque énergie c'est de passer de 600
millions à 1,8 milliard de soutien mais
s'écrira les gens quand ils réchauffent
c'est formidable vous savez pas comment
fonctionne le chéquier z et en vous êtes
incohérences inquiet parce qu'ils ne
savent pas comment fonctionne
aujourd'hui c'est avec les gens
tiens la transition tout à fait non
c'est un chat qui souffre c'est d'un
chèque de soutien la transition vous
savez même pas vous savez pas comment ça
fonctionne quand on demande d'investir
sur y compris d'accélérer les prime à la
conversion
j'ai prendre deux exemples je vais
prendre deux exemples est doublé c'est
ce que vous demandez pour la voiture que
j'ai su alors il est doublé sur les
ménages les 20% pour des des ménages les
plus pauvres
c'est même pas les non-imposables c'est
même pas le doublement sur l'ensemble de
nos impôts sable prenons deux exemples
vous avez deux lignes de chemin de fer
la ligne firminy saint-etienne
investissements de la région des
collectivités pour électrifier vous avez
une lignes cadencées tous les quarts
d'heure les gens déposent leur voiture
au parking de firminy ils prennent le
train pour se rendre au boulot à
saint-etienne un excellent exemple qui
permet de réduire la facture des ménages
vous prenez un autre exemple la ligne
caen le mans tours sète les halles
devrait fonctionner elle vous devriez
être devrait elle devrait fonctionner à
120 km/heure ok elle fonctionne à 60
kilomètres/heure et là aussi c'est une
ligne qui est utilisé pour le pour aller
au boulot dans votre réforme de la sncf
vous renvoyer à l'ensemble des
collectivités le maintien de 7 à 9 me
kilomètres de pau centre
voilà une irresponsable en valais on
regarde des besoins suivante jean
françois husson
enfin moi je voulais vous parler puisque
vous êtes candidat également pour être
tête de liste aux élections européennes
je suis tête de liste et voila donc
voilà faut faire bouger un sérieux atout
c'est que vous êtes vous n'êtes pas des
candidats voilà parce que
il faudra que vous mettiez un peu
d'accord dans la famille me semble utile
dans la famille de ce que j'ai cru
comprendre comme étant plutôt de gauche
j'ai un service des eaux et que vous
êtes les élections européennes
finalement on sent monter une vague de
protestation générale dans les pays pour
des raisons multiples et diverses
aujourd'hui on est également dans une
période où les incertitudes et les
tensions internationales sont fortes
il suffit de regarder la planète sans
être un grand expert une nécessité de
plus et mieux d'europe
finalement d'une renaissance de l'esprit
européen me semble nécessaire mais dans
le contexte et que les quel contexte
actuel
que voulez-vous faire en matière de
sécurité intérieure et extérieure
et quand je dit extérieurs c'est quelle
est votre position dans une europe dont
je crois que vous voulez qu'elle soit 1
fédéral et deuxièmement pour une une
défense européenne
j'ai toujours soutenu l'idée d'une
on a notamment en europe à peu près deux
millions soldats financer comme karim
benzema répond et on a deux millions de
soldats la réalité d'une défense
européenne efficace serait 300000 il y à
un une capacité à renforcer les
coopérations y compris technologiques
les coopérations militaires y compris
sur les appels d'offres on perd des
milliards et des milliards à faire
chaque pays
ces appels d'offres en matière de
matériel militaire d'équipement des
soldats tout ça et de perfectionner nos
équipements souvenez vous pourquoi
finalement le général de villiers se met
en situation difficile avec le président
macron et qu'il est viré c'est parce
qu'il dit j'en ai marre de voir vous
êtes à répondre c'est un point important
j'en ai marre de voir mes soldats se
faire tuer parce qu'ils n'ont pas le bon
équipement
donc on a une capacité à construire une
défense européenne
j'y suis favorable parce que c'est un
pilier essentiel d'avoir une politique
ans et reconnaît armés parlant de mary
ticket qu'il avait senti des larmes et
heureux
non mais une défense européenne avec une
armée européenne sous l'autorité de qui
parce que c'est ça l'ambiguïté chez vous
la remet aujourd'hui on n'y est pas faut
parfois des charges et le score je vois
la libé lyon vous horrible et aux fans
amis liste que vous n'étiez pas pendant
des années donc là j'ai bossé moi non
mais en fait en permanence des procès
passés je raconte ce que je dis je fais
pas un procès je le redis aujourd'hui
j'ai je regarde quel est votre parcours
et celui de votre formation politique
c'est tous ces écoutes ça paraît
cohérent moi j'ai pas de souci on peut
parler de nos formations politiques
vous avez toujours pas de tête de liste
moi je vois les votes de vos collègues
par exemple al m'étonnais voilà je vois
vos votes
les votes de vos collègues au parlement
européen il vote compte toutes les
mesures vous parlez du réglementaire sur
la pollution c'est eux qui votent en
permanence pour réduire les ambitions
sur les normes sur les normes ses bases
hall il m'avait pas fait durer par an au
passage le diesel c'est vrai 10000 morts
prématurées normes on sait déjà tueur et
ses 48 mille morts prématurées en france
toutes causes confondues c'est juste
pour remettre de la vérité et de la
justice
mais attendez vous dit deux choses non
non je ne fais pas les choses il est
justement dans mon rapport et aucun
souci 48 mille morts prématurés liés à
la pollution de l'air se disent ce que
disent les experts
c'est la concentration diesel sur un
certain nombre de villes et tout ça on
serait à dix mille morceaux
giuly façon je vous avais ce que disent
les experts il exact mais n'est pas
d'accord mais sauf ce dîner xavier c'est
pas pareil regardez ce que des élections
alors on sort des querelles de chiffres
wii party un petit peu au dessus ce que
je fasse un débat de politique
politicienne je passe sur qui rassure
monsieur jadot qui me prend de haut par
rapport à mon âge et puis les débats sur
leur site web
j'entends ça suffit on était assez moi
je pense maintenant
n'est ce pas moi est quelque chose qui
m'a choqué vous avez soutenu une
proposition qui avait d'ailleurs été
fait par mes collègues députés aient
l'air qui était chèque carburant de son
reflet soutenu et quelques semaines on
bat 6,1 à 6,6 je vous invite à regarder
ce qu'ils étaient
on n'a pas soutenu si vous l'avez
soutenu vous allez faire ses griffes si
vous êtes gentil je sais à peu près ce
que je raconte moi ce que vous racontez
ou alors expliquez nous avec moi
effectivement mais je dois vous
l'envoyez pas parce que je vais me faire
dire ça je sous leur vrai quoi qu'il
arrive ce chèque carburant que vous avez
soutenu moi je le maintiens je suis
désolé diot s'est d'abord vous avez vous
savez on dit rêver vous allez finir
démenti l'équipe ans régis ils peuvent
regarder parce que c'est une question
sur le chèque énergie non c'était sur
chaque camion mais puisque vous n'êtes
pas d'accord
comme m car la question tombe moi je
trouve toujours aussi incohérent je suis
désolé parce que entre ce que vous dites
est ce que vous faites
d'ailleurs vous en tant qu au moment des
élections européennes assez bizarrement
il ya quand même tout un monde
ah bon et aujourd'hui arrêter de nous
prendre tous les français veulent mieux
que ça mais vous savez quand vous
essayez le grand bain d'accord vous avez
de mauvaises informations sur ce que je
déclare vous savez les combats le jeu
mais nous parlementaires des combats je
l'espère pour plus d'écologie com -
l'heure d'accord
l'interdiction de la pêche électrique
qui a gagné c'est bon mais le
gouvernement français soutient pas
d'interdiction de la pêche électrique
cette fois on a même fini recruter alors
je dois je aller mais moi ce que je sais
c'est que je voudrais que les gens de
résolution européenne pour le divertir
la pêche s'est battu avec cadec député
et l'air mais le gouvernement français
dans les compromis du conseil ne défend
pas l'interdiction définitive de la
pêche a écrite pour protéger nos
pêcheurs artisans je suis pas le
gouvernement je suis parlementaire avant
d'eau d'accord la douce par la
commission européenne d'ailleurs
l'interdiction l'huile de palme
l'interaction de la pêche électrique moi
j'ai on a voté une femme à une
proposition de résolution européenne qui
visait à interdire justement la pêche
électrique a eu l'idée de l air viendra
celui dont vous avez voté comme en plus
le pas mon choix
le chèque énergie et non pas le chèque
carburant s'est alors ça n'a rien à voir
une précision importante monsieur le
député monsieur le sénateur sur un autre
sujet puisqu'il est d'abord éminemment
européen il était dans les fondements
dans les dents le pilier de la
construction européenne c'est la
politique agricole commune la culture
française et la culture au caire la
culture française traverse une crise
majeure avec
population qui travaille beaucoup et qui
ne trouve aujourd'hui plus par leur
travail par le fruit de leur travail
de quoi vivre décemment vous savez
aujourd'hui plus de 40% des france des
agriculteurs ont moins de 500 euros par
mois pour que tout le monde comprenne
moins de 500 euros par mois net
aujourd'hui à de vrais débats sur les
enjeux d'une agriculture raisonnée bio
et sur la manière de construire un
nouveau modèle d'agriculture plus
respectueuse de l'environnement mais qui
assure à la fois notre souveraineté
nationale et qui continuent d'être avec
des capacités d'exportation
comment inscrivez vous je dirais le
projet écologique que vous portez
aujourd'hui au service de la culture
française alors sur la réforme de la
politique agricole commune c'est à peu
près 9 milliards d'euros d'argent public
qui soutient l'agriculture en france
d'accord c'est la contribution
européenne à l'agriculture française
plus pour ajouter 4 milliard quasiment
d'euros d'argent public français
c'est considérable et effectivement vous
l'avez mentionné avec des résultats qui
sont loin d'être à la hauteur de ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer avec autant
d'argent depuis tant d'années au moins
un tiers des agriculteurs qui vivent
avec moins 350 euros un suicide tous les
jours tous les deux jours une une
défiance des consommateurs des citoyens
vis-à-vis des agriculteurs dont parfois
vous entretenez avec le travail je
travaille avec beaucoup d'agriculteurs
de paysans pour faire quoi pour faire
que cet argent aille pour des
agriculteurs qui vont à la fois faire de
la valeur ajoutée et la valeur ajoutée
c'est pas de faire du buzz congelés
exporté en arabie saoudite ou de contes
d'essayer concurrencer les brésiliens
sur le marché chinois
c'est de faire de la valeur ajoutée dans
notre pays et la valeur ajoutée c'est ce
qui en plus permettra de d'avoir des
agriculteurs qui respecte les animaux
des agriculteurs qui respecte
l'environnement et des agriculteurs qui
sont le pilier d'un truc extraordinaire
qu'on a en france qu'ils appellent la
gastronomie
aujourd'hui malheureusement cette
politique agricole commune participe
davantage d'une mondialisation de la
malbouffe que vous soutenez avec vos
collègues à travers les accords de libre
échange avec le mercosur ou avec le
canada est pas à fond à offrir un avenir
à nos campagnes offrir un avenir à nos
paysans et protéger l'environnement
comme protéger notre santé
c'est ça notre objectif voilà la réponse
merci messieurs merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à cette confrontation
on arrive tout de suite à la troisième
partie d'auditions publiques avec nos
deux journalistes femmes
yannick jadot vous les attendiez qui
arrive avec donc oriane mancini avait
débouché bonsoir mesdames c'est une
question d'un internaute du figaro live
qui demande sur le chat est ce que vous
pensez yannick jadot que la voiture
électrique est l'avenir de la transition
écologique
oui non elle y participe et anticipe la
voiture électrique parce que notamment
une voiture électrique en ville c'est
une voiture qui n'émet pas de pollution
donc c'est important vis ma meilleure
amie de claire j'ai envie de dire mais
si ça le problème c'est que vous voyez
on a quand même des déchets pour des
centaines de milliers d'années on a des
batteries au lithium en a on a enfin une
batterie au lithium qui explose c'est
pas comme un réacteur nucléaire qui
explose donc après une voiture
électrique elle a besoin d'électricité
et l'électricité si elle vient des
énergies renouvelables c'est parfait ça
ne vient pas des énergies renouvelables
c'est une autre pollution mais attention
l'enjeu de la transition sur la mobilité
ça n'est pas de remplacer toutes les
voitures par d'autres voitures c'est de
permettre à nos concitoyens de prendre
un tram train de prendre un but de
prendre et leur peur de faire de la
levée du corps et les rails c'est vous
voulait pas nuire les priver de voiture
que tôt mais pourquoi il ya une quantité
considérable de transport y compris en
voiture qui font moins de 1km
est-ce qu'on peut pas proposer des
alternatives plus tôt que la bagnole sur
moins de 1km
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire en sorte que
nos concitoyens dans les zones rurales
il est un moment donné à prendre leur
voiture mais qu'ils puissent déposer
leur voiture dans un parking faire du
covoiturage avec leurs collègues et que
ce covoiturage soit rentrer dans les
indemnités kilométriques qui sont
remboursés par les entreprises ça c'est
facile en fait une question sur la
législative partielle dans l'essonne qui
a eu lieu ce dimanche le premier tour
feront si ce choix est arrivé en tête
devant farida amrani pour la france
insoumise tout dépendra du ravin reports
de voix et face à ce qui est la
candidate ps europe ecologie les verts
est arrivé quatrième avec quelques 10 %
des voix et ce qu'elle doit appeler à
voter pour un candidat et pour lequel
s'est parfaitement exprimée elle a dit
qu'elle laissait les électeurs libres de
leur choix je crois qu'aujourd'hui dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui les électeurs
c'est pas des boîtes de petits pois dont
on change l'état gère ça veut dire que
tu as eu lieu pour europe ecologie les
verts n'y a pas de choix à faire entre
un candidat très proche de manuel macro
et un candidat avec la déclaration est
très claire elle a dit que la liste
qu'elle porte un mail à la question vous
avez la liste qu'elle portait et et ne
se reconnaissaient ni dans une liste ni
dans l'autre et vous vous sentez plus
proche des manuels maquereau ou la
france un service je me sens proche de
l'écologie est beau aujourd'hui nous
sommes les seuls à avoir la
détermination à affronter les lobbys
apporté au parlement européen ou dans
les municipalités où dans les
collectivités territoriales comme les
régions a porté cette transition
écologique qui créent des emplois
surtout nos territoires qui offre qui
permet d'améliorer le pouvoir d'achat
et vous savez quand vous avez de
l'activité économique les bains vous
avez des services publics vous avez de
la culture et vous avez de la démocratie
pour ça que je défends les terroirs
on va parler de l'europe emmanuel macron
et et hier à berlin dans son discours il
a dit l'europe est en son sein le couple
franco-allemand se trouve investi de
l'obligation de ne pas laisser le monde
glisser dans le chaos c'est de la
lucidité ou de la dramatisation de la
famille
l'état c'est de la lucidité moi je
j'applaudis des deux mains les discours
d' emmanuel macron sur l'europe
quand il dit à quel point il faut de la
souveraineté européenne il faut une
europe qui protège
il avait parlé de la souveraineté
climatique de la souveraineté
alimentaire il dit à quel point les
extrêmes droites en train de s'emparer
de l'europe
tous ces discours là j'applaudis des
deux mains mon problème c'est ce qu'il
fait quand il dit j'ai zappé n'est ce
pas ah ben non
aujourd'hui finalement il s'est rangé
avec l'allemagne on nous explique angela
merkel est faible que c'est un problème
pour le couple franco allemand
alors il ya deux ans on nous expliquait
qu'en gallen merkel était fort que c'est
un problème pour le couple franco
allemand
il ya un moment donné il va falloir
qu'on sache si on sait faire même avec
angela merkel en difficulté de quoi on a
besoin aujourd'hui en europe
est-ce qu'on se range finalement sur une
forme de grand statu quo des accords de
libre échange qui participent de
l'emballement climatique qui participe
de la mondialisation de la malbouffe ou
de la mondialisation de la souffrance
animale
hess comporte al'inverse plutôt l'idée
que c'est ce que veulent les écologistes
ouvrir au fond un nouvelle page de
l'histoire de l'europe en faisant du
dérèglement climatique et de
l'anéantissement de la biodiversité le
coeur de nos politiques parce que si on
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
si on lutte pour la biodiversité on
décline
après l'ensemble y compris de notre
géopolitique dépendent du soleil du vent
de l'eau ou de la chaleur du sol plutôt
que de poutine des pétromonarchies du
golfe ou de trump c'est quand même une
autre vision qu'on adopte offrir
jeunesse des emplois surtout nos
territoires
un espoir un projet partagé autour de
l'avenir mais comment les écologistes
sincère finalement dans ce débat qui a
installé entre nationalistes et
progressistes mais c'est de la blague ce
débat pardonnez moi c'est moi je refuse
et larnack libérales et les hold-up
populiste l'écologie c'est au fond je
pense qu'on est le seul mouvement
politique qui a la lucidité du monde
dans lequel on vit
emmanuel macron
comme ses collègues européens quand ils
défendent un modèle de développement qui
amènent des trajets infinie aujourd'hui
dans les zones rurales mais qui amène à
l'échelle globale
un modèle de développement qui est deux
fois plus gros que la planète qui
explosent les limites de la planète qui
maltraitent les femmes et les hommes
il participe finalement du chaos
je ferai jamais la décroissance par
exemple c'est pas de croissance
pardonnez moi j'ai parlé dans toute
cette émission d'investissement oui j'ai
parlé tout cette émission
d'investissement est ce que la france
comme elle le fait aujourd'hui avec son
gouvernement investit dans les forages
de total en guyane est-ce qu'elle
investit dans les mines d'or pour qui
vont constructive vont conduire à une
déforestation nazis est-ce qu'elle
continue à importer de l'huile de palme
qui participe de la déforestation en
indonésie en malaisie
est-ce qu'elle porte ce modèle là malgré
tous les discours vous êtes très
sympathique belle croissance
je suis pour un mode de développement et
qui joue sur les enjeux du climat de la
biodiversité parce qu'aujourd'hui ces
enjeux sont sacrées des secteurs
économiques qui permet de l'emploi et de
l'activité économique
il faut pas qu europe ecologie les verts
se rapproche d'autres groupes de gauche
et notamment de place publique qui est
un mouvement issu de la société civile
est ce que c'est pas comme cela que
daniel cohn bendit avait réussi à faire
ces 16% en 2009
mais moi j'ai pas de soucis place
publique ce sont mes amis savent et
claire nouvian par exemple qui est une
des porte-parole de place publique
mon pays j'ai vu que même bien sûr ouais
enfin soit 6 et le finish
oui mais enfin s'il avait aujourd'hui
vous savez on a beaucoup milité ensemble
on a signé début on a fait meeting
commun souvent à la réunion publique sur
alep et tout ça
attendez quand on parle de pourquoi je
parle de tiers nous vient parce que
claire nouvian elle préside bloom qui
est une association de protection des
océans
elle a mobilisé d'une manière
remarquable l'opinion publique sur la
pêche en eau profonde sur la pêche
électrique mais qui a fait le boulot
parlement
pardonnez moi c'est moi c'est moi qui
est mobilisé et construire des majorités
au parlement pour qu'on arrête la pêche
en eau profonde pour qu'on arrête la
pêche la grippe donc on est parfaitement
complémentaire ne faites pas comme une
heure mais il j'ai pas vu qu'ils disent
annoncé qu'ils allaient faire une liste
aux européennes
est-ce que vous avez vu qu'ils
annonçaient qu'il faisait une liste aux
européennes ont proposé pour eux aussi
en même temps avaient changé maintenant
mais moi je veux bien réfléchir à toutes
les options mais pardonnez moi est-ce
que place publique a dit nous montons
une liste aux européennes
oui non mais vous savez quand donc je
vais pas me positionner sur un truc qui
n'existe pas on propose régulièrement de
me positionner sur ségolène royal est ce
que c'est vrai les noyales a annoncé
qu'elle tire une liste aux européennes
vont bien on parle d'une liste mais n'a
pas dit ni socialistes écologistes
portées par ségolène royal
mais c'est qu'ils ont ça vous inquiète
mais parce qu'il m'a scié rumeurs donc
vous me demandez de commenter une rumeur
non ce serait pas impossible
elle est la seule chose la seule chose
que je l' ai entendu dire c'est je ne
veux pas être député de base pardonnez
moi moi je suis très fier des députés de
base quand on gagne sur l'huile de palme
quand on gagne sur la pêche quand on
gagne sur les énergies renouvelables
quand on gagne sur les paysans quand on
gagne sur la protection de notre
industrie photovoltaïque menacé par les
chinois je suis très fier d'être à la
place où je suis c'est mon combat
je suis très fier ça veut pas être
députée européenne je n'imagine pas
qu'elle puisse se présenter à l'élection
européenne ou ou alors c'est une rumeur
en allemagne en allemagne les
écologistes réalisent des scores élevés
de même en belgique aux pays-bas en
luxembourg luxembourg pourquoi en france
vous n'y arrivez pas vous êtes crédité
de 7% se vernir vous savez en allemagne
dont il était l'invité de trajectoire
alors puisqu'on a beaucoup parlé de la
trajectoire d'un homme élève et adil
vous à votre politiquement vos
trajectoires donc à metz avec la la la
croissance ça avec la croissance de la
trajectoire
ça va être la version de la cour de la
tendance non je n'en vaut viser
16% mais moi je si vous voulez j'ai dit
que notre potentiel
c'était autour de 15% mais ma seule
volonté c'est que si je crois à ce que
je dis c'est à dire que c'est le cas il
faut sauver l'europe
aujourd'hui l'europe est en train de se
disloquer
j'entends ce qu'ils vont faire le
référendum anti macron c'est qu'ils ont
déserté le combat européen
je suis désolé l'europe le problème
c'est pas que macron ya salvini jordaan
il y en a d'autres l'explication livrée
hier par françois de rugy à votre faible
score pour le moment c'est que les verts
français sont du son dans une
radicalisation proche de l'extrême
gauche qu'est ce que vous lui répondez
vous qu'est-ce que je dise françois de
rugy et et europe ecologie les verts
quand ils pensaient que
c'était plus facile d'être élu il est
passé au parti socialiste
maintenant il est passé en marge
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je dise
moi je marche du questionnement
non mais tout ça c'est le passé moi je
veux rompre avec ces comportements là
pour moi l'écologie encore une fois je
pense que nous sommes le seul mouvement
politique qui soit lucide sur le monde
dans lequel nous vivons et je veux si je
crois à ce point qu'il faut sauver
l'europe pour offrir un avenir à nos
enfants pour sauver le climat pour
sauver la biodiversité je veux que mon
courant de pensée politique devienne le
premier courant pour ses politiques de
notre pays
lorsque je crois raison de redouter une
percée des écologistes j'ai pas à
commenter ce que pense emmanuel macron
je vous dis ce que je pense être bien
pour nous comme pour nos enfants
moi voyez imaginer un break sitter un
parent anglais qu'à voter pour le break
site
quand il regarde ses enfants et lui dit
quoi jeter fermer les portes du
continent je t'ai bouffe chez ton
horizons j'étais boucher l'horizon sur
le monde
ça peut pas être sain quand même ce
qu'on offre à nos enfants mais ça peut
pas être non plus la compétition de tous
contre tous les salariés contre les
salariés les territoires contre les
territoires les choix de société quand
les choix de société
ce que porte le libéralisme européen et
donc moi je veux incarner en tant que
tête de liste mais avec toute la liste
avec tous les écologistes que nous
rassemblons je veux un quart à sion
nicolas hulot par exemple sortir de son
silence jeudi dans une émission sur
france 2 émission politique
est-ce que vous pensez que nicolas hulot
va soutenir les actions du gouvernement
la fiscalité écologique puisque après
tout il en est aussi à l'origine est ce
que vous vous avez eu des contacts avec
lui depuis son départ du gouvernement
qu'est-ce qui est ce qu'il a dit 1 c'est
quand il est parti il a dit je vais
tranquille mais c'est moi tranquille
laissez moi prendre du recul que
personne ne me récupère donc j'ai pas
commencer à
être en contradiction avec ses demandes
puisque j'ai entendu quand il est parti
quand même c'est au fond ce gouvernement
est gangréné par les lobbys sur
l'agriculture sur l'énergie sur la
fiscalité et ce qu'il a toujours porté
nicolas hulot mais comme tous les
écologistes c'est que la fiscalité écolo
elne écolo que si elle est juste et
solidaire souvenez-vous du message moi
je me souviens de nicolas sarkozy le
premier à avoir parlé de la taxe carbone
il comparait la taxe carbone à la
décolonisation le le le
l'abolition de la peine de mort
l'élection au suffrage universel il
disait tout ça et quand il a commandé le
rapport à michel rocard à ce moment là
michel rocard a dit attention il ne peut
y avoir de fiscalité écolo que si elle
est juste que si c'est un bâillon à
prendre ses distances avec chaussures là
je vous demandais ce que nicolas hulot
mais aujourd'hui rien qui me soutiennent
mais j'attends j'attends de nicolas
hulot qui joue comme d'habitude ce rôle
de 2,2 de faire de la pédagogie sont son
rôle de lanceur dallaire d'éveilleur de
conscience parce qu'on a terriblement
besoin de se mobiliser collectivement à
la fois pour engager la transition
mais pour que cette transition soit
juste social puisque vous guettez la
constitution ou pas des listes pour les
élections européennes il y en a une qui
est annoncé dans votre créneau ce matin
eric jadot c'est aymeric caron qu'on
connaît bien comme chroniqueur également
comme vegan et qui annonce donc une
liste du rassemblement des écologistes
pour le vivant votre réaction sur ce
point et puis également sur le fait
qu'il vous critique d'art vous avez
dénoncé les vegan qui cèdent aux
violences oui je pense que ça n'aide pas
le combat sur lequel nous sommes
et je suis extrêmement investis contre
la souffrance animale notamment dans les
élevages industriels
je pense qu'à partir du moment où on
s'attaque à des charcutiers a débouché
on se trompe totalement de combat et que
encore une fois on perd du coup
de vue ce combat juste contre l'aso
concédant qu'il faille sa liste il fait
ce qu'il veut et week-end je dire j'ai
pas il y as qui avec lui ah ben on ne
sait pas encore quand quant à lui l'a
très bien montré d'une autre sujet vous
en avez brièvement parlé tout à l'heure
le projet de montagne d'or oui projet de
mine d'or géante qui devrait voir le
jour en guyane d'ici 2022 alors face aux
critiques les promoteurs ont décidé de
revoir leurs projets pour réduire au
maximum les impacts sur l'environnement
ils disent se rapprocher du projet de
mine responsable voulue par emmanuel
macron est-ce que selon vous l'état va
leur accorder le feu vert je crains mais
je me battrai jusqu'au bout pour que ce
soit pas le cas
d'ailleurs le rapport du la commission
nationale du débat public où est
quasiment j'ai pas combien 98 2 99% des
avis sont contre le projet mine d'or
c'était dédié en fait le problème c'est
que le gouvernement n'a jamais posé la
bonne question est ce que on met en
place des mines d'or en guyane ou pas
pour l'instant on fait de l'exploitation
ce qu'on appelle alluvionnaires d'accord
légal ou illégal il faudrait lutter
beaucoup plus sévèrement contre
l'exploit et les leur pillage illégal
mais creuser pour créer des montagnes de
bon avec du cyanure avec des métaux
lourds tout ça c'est prendre une
responsabilité majeure c'est prendre un
risque extraordinaire qui finira
toujours par retomber sur l'ensemble des
habitants sur l'ensemble des populations
locales
750 emplois à la clé trois mille emplois
indirects
moi j'ai lu le rappeler les promoteurs
sur le décalage et 90% de la collation
niveau local des employés au niveau
local pour des centaines de milliers
d'euros par an poil ray en guyane est ce
que le la guyane est un territoire
délaissé par la république deux fois
plus de chômage et un niveau de vie est
très intéressant au niveau de vie très
inférieur à la métropole
et donc quand on a une situation
économie comme ça ce qu'on propose c'est
de saccager la forêt et de forêts au
pétrole donc c'est de dire en fait vous
avez un trésor qui est la biodiversité
c'est notre amazonie c'est notre
amazonie celle amazonie française et
d'un seul coup
virer la coop 21 l'accord de paris sur
le climat virer tous les discours sur la
biodiversité
on va saccager avec un projet et des
dizaines d'autres qui vont aller voir
derrière dit que vous allez vous battre
6 organisation amérindienne on en voyait
aujourd'hui une lettre ouverte à
emmanuel macron si la montagne d'or ne
recule pas nous allons droit vers
l'affrontement mais c'est certain qu'on
dirige sondés citent j'y suis allé sur
place
j'ai travaillé avec les amérindiens et
notamment les jeunesse autochtone ce
sont des sites sacrés on est en train de
détruire non seulement la forêt on est
en train de créer un risque c'est au
brésil il ya trois ans dans une telle
situation il ya rupture de barrage sur
les déchets ce sont des dizaines des
centaines des milliers de personnes qui
ne peuvent plus vivre ce sont des morts
c'est une biodiversité détruit pour des
générations est ce qu'on n'a pas autre
chose à offrir aux guyanais qu'un projet
de dévastation de l'environnement et ben
oui il ya l'agriculture l'écotourisme
l'agroforesterie la pêche tout ça sont
des secteurs qui sont bien plus
créateurs d'emplois d'emplois durables
en coûtant beaucoup moins d'argent aux
contribuables minutes qu'on a présenté
sa feuille de route énergétique pour les
dix ans à venir d'ici la fin du mois
qu'est ce que vous vous attendez de
cette fameuse ppe programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie le respect de
la loi le respect de la loi c'est la loi
de transition énergétique qui a été
votée report a été votée à aller voter
voter en 2015 après un an de débats
publics et qui disait quoi ils disaient
il faut réduire le nucléaire pour enfin
laisser de la place aux énergies
renouvelables
aujourd'hui ce que je vois c'est que
edouard philippe
le grand homme d'areva lobbyiste en chef
d' areva qui au gouvernement problème
des décisions les annonces avant même
qu'ils aient conclusions des
concertations et du débat public
on va reprendre vie qui achètent des
terres autour de ses centrales
nucléaires pour éventuellement permettre
de nouvelles en france est totalement
absurde
vous êtes vous connaissez on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé de la situation de la
sncf la situation d'edf est bien pire du
point de vue financier on est au moins à
40 milliards d'endettement des murs
d'investir
de 100 à 150 milliards simplement pour
mettre aux normes
nos centrales nucléaires qui sont de
plus en plus d'être du nucléaire mais
comme tout le monde les énergies
renouvelables coûte deux fois moins cher
que le nucléaire aujourd'hui et pourquoi
est ce que nous ont saisis renouvelables
aujourd'hui en travaux il ya seulement
16%
la blanche parce que jean la mandature
on a toujours tout donné au nucléaire
deux dernières questions sur une
déclaration polémique du week end
questions sur la pma et cette
déclaration de laurent wauquiez qui
était devant sens commun il dit que pour
lui la pma la gpa mènera à l'eugénisme
propre au régime nazi est ce qu'on est
face à l'idée c'est minable
à force de courir après le front
national il va vraiment se faire selon
vous tiens c'est minable minable voilà
c'est votre dernier mot et qu'on
supprime au nom même adresse que trouver
un autre baisse si vous voulez
l'écologie part à la conquête de
l'europe parce qu'on a un formidable
programme on a compris que vous avez
parlé pendant une heure merci beaucoup
il ya un examen on va suivre très vite à
votre trajectoire donc
politiques et électorales jusqu'au
européenne merci à vous a bientôt merci
madame
la semaine prochaine c'est jacqueline
gourault la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires qui sera notre invité
bonsoir a très vite